as our withdrawal from afghanistan comes
to an end we are finally getting an idea
of just how much we are leaving behind
according to a government watchdog group
the government won't give us these
numbers but the watchdog group will the
united states is leaving behind
75 000 vehicles
600 000
weapons
208 aircrafts
and very likely 1 000 americans that the
government just can't evacuate
biden continues to stonewall the press
which is hard to trust to begin with in
light of a new study
showing that just 22 percent of cable
news is actually news
but the word is getting out and people
seem to trust the liberal gatekeepers
less and less each day which is how a
conservative fox news host has become
the new king of late night top ratings
among all of late night and how a
conservative radio host may very well
become the next governor of california
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
noll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from old school who
says
little do the afghan refugees know that
they are simply fleeing one radical
dictatorship to enter another that is
true they will be going from the the
taliban run
country into the country run by
ton ton hamad ibn farooq al fauci who is
the supreme enlightened mullah of the
progress progressive public health
dictatorship it's enough to just give
you a lot of stress you know it's enough
to just get you feeling all ah get your
blood pumping
when you want good iron pumping around
your blood i'd recommend you check out
good ranchers did you know that over 80
percent of the grass-fed beef sold in
the u.s is imported from overseas
now the good ranchers have traveled the
country on a mission to help the
american family by working together with
local farms and ranches and shipping
straight to your door
goodranchers.com is a safe and
convenient way to order your meat they
save your family money
they help the american farmer
goodranchers.com they deliver american
craft beef better than organic chicken
they've got t-bones fillets strips
gourmet burgers and more i had the
gourmet burgers for dinner about what
four or five nights ago and they were
excellent they were superb i the strips
are fabulous too those those are
generally my kind of cuts that i would
go for they've got unbelievable quality
really great prices you'll be helping
america putting america first go to
goodranchers.com to buy now or subscribe
today to save 20 on each box of
mouth-watering meats subscribing brings
the cost down to less than five bucks a
meal plus right now get an additional 20
bucks off and free express shipping if
you go to goodranchers.com
knowles use code knowles at checkout 20
bucks off and free express shipping at
goodranchers.com knowles know where your
meat comes from with goodranchers.com
how much are we leaving behind in
afghanistan
i think when people hear that we left
some military equipment in afghanistan
they're thinking oh yeah we left a crate
of guns oh yeah we left some uniforms
probably left maybe a helicopter or two
uh maybe we left some trucks and humvees
and stuff
no we left an army's worth of of
extremely powerful weaponry the most
powerful weaponry on earth
75 000 vehicles 600 000 weapons 208
aircraft
that is
a lot
since 2001
the united states has spent
83
billion
dollars
on afghan security forces and training
and equipment
for the alleged afghan nation and the
afghan national security that folded
instantly
like the very second that we said we
were going to leave they just completely
folded which is really insult to injury
it is really salt in the wound because
not only did we invade to get rid of the
taliban and now the taliban is right
back
but all we've really accomplished sure
we killed bin laden in pakistan we
killed a bunch of other terrorists in
the meantime
but today as a matter of geopolitics
who's running what nations
all we really manage to accomplish
is give billions of dollars of arms to
the government that we said we were
going to kick out because they harbored
the terrorists that perpetrated 911.
that
that is the sort of incompetence that it
is very difficult to wrap your head
around until you hear
those numbers
according to this watchdog group that
said we found a federal audit that
detailed up to 200 million dollars worth
of drones
that had disappeared just gone
we don't know where the 600 000 weapons
are within the country and then beyond
the stuff i just got an alert yesterday
on my phone popped up from the wall
street journal
alert
the u.s believes that 1500 americans are
still in afghanistan and is actively in
touch with and trying to evacuate 500 of
them secretary of state lincoln said
uh
okay go on give me more uh it seems a
natural question would be
what about the other thousand so you're
saying there's 1500 americans still in
afghanistan for some reason
and the state department is in touch
with 500 of them so you're in touch with
one third of the americans stuck in
afghanistan you're not even in touch
with the other thousand let alone you're
gonna be able to get them out
how
how do you i was talking to my wife last
night
sweet little alisa very perceptive young
woman
doesn't work in politics professionally
doesn't study international relations
military
state craft and yet she had a very good
question which is you know we've been
planning this evacuation for years at
this point for many years at this point
um and you got the military there and
you got the civilians there
wouldn't
and
forgive my ignorance wouldn't it have
maybe made more sense to get the
american civilians out first
i don't know i'm not klaus fitz i'm not
matter nick but it seems to me that
might have been smart
a little too smart it turns out for our
federal government biden was asked about
this he gave a press conference yeah
again about buildback better and we're
gonna you know we're gonna fund pre-k
and so the police don't ask me about
afghanistan
he gave this
statement i can't even say it's a press
conference because he doesn't take
questions from the press he is asked at
the very end of it what about the other
americans
he's got nothing
thank you all very much
and thank the press for being here we're
going to go private now mr president if
americans are still in afghanistan
we're going to go private
what's the difference what have you been
doing
yeah there's that smurf
mr president what about the americans
what are the americans still there the
smirk and then you hear that the clip is
still going on
but
they cut it's still it's he's still
playing right now but the white house
cut the microphone
because the the white house
one they've they've clearly told joe
biden do not answer any questions about
the americans that you are stranding in
afghanistan
but two they don't even trust him to be
able to resist
so maybe he doesn't turn his back and
run away this time maybe he does
accidentally give the press an answer
and so they actually cut his microphone
disrespectful not only to
the press disrespectful not only to the
american people obviously very
disrespectful to the americans stuck in
afghanistan
disrespectful to the president
they're just going to
can't let joe answer an urgent question
from the press by the way
so the the current estimate is that
they're the americans are only going to
strand a thousand of their own people in
afghanistan only a thousand
but
we just had a report there's apparently
a serious threat of a terror attack at
the kabul airport
this is where
all of the americans are now this is
this is the epicenter of the of the
withdrawal because we gave up the air
base for some stupid reason so
we've got just the kabul airport now is
how we're going to get people out of
afghanistan and isis k this is the new
ice isis ii electric boogaloo has come
back they're apparently warring with the
taliban because let's not forget well
we've pretended that we've just been
building up a country all these years
and only fighting the taliban
afghanistan is in the midst of a civil
war
and sure we're backing certain forces
there but there are a lot of forces at
play one of which is this offshoot of
isis and so isis is threatening to
attack the airport so now the taliban
and the u.s are saying get away from the
airport do not come there so it's
slowing the evacuation even more but the
the withdrawal date is still firm the
taliban won't back down and joe biden
doesn't have a spine so august 31st
we've got to be completely out of there
the number of americans we strand could
be much much
higher
mr president what about them he just
smirks he smirks in park because he
doesn't have an answer this is the joke
classic joe biden tactic when he doesn't
have an answer for something he just
kind of laughs and giggles and smiles
he used it on paul ryan in the 2012 vice
presidential debates it's it's really
infuriating but it's all he's got
because there's not too much going on
between his ears
speaking
of questionable air travel practices
how's that for a segway delta airlines
is
going to be charging unvaccinated
employees 200 dollars per month extra
on their health care bills
if they refuse to take the job
the reason is they say that the
hospitalizations for the unvaccinated
employees they're very high and so quote
this surcharge will be necessary to
address the financial risk the decision
to not vaccinate is creating for our
company
in recent weeks since the rise of the
b.1.617.2 variant all delta employees
who have been hospitalized with covid
were not fully vaccinated
okay fine whatever i under the policy we
don't even need to get into that i'm
just curious
and
maybe you've heard about this and i just
haven't
the b point one
point six one seven point two variant
of covid uh
oh you mean the delta variant
it's a delta airlines
doesn't doesn't want to use the the new
politically correct term delta for the
the covid variant because that doesn't
make them look good it's just bad pr
but they also don't want to use the the
term indian variant which is what it was
called in the first place but then it
was deemed politically incorrect because
you're not allowed to refer to
non-western countries that that create
viruses you're allowed to call call them
refer to them by western countries like
the the uk variant for instance or even
the south african variant we called that
for a while because that's like sort of
a you know there's obviously there's a
complicated racial history to south
africa but the indian variant you're not
allowed to say china virus you're not
allowed to say
so
delta as a very politically correct
airline is really really stuck between a
rock and a hard place this is where
we're going as society
i mean forget covet for a second forget
delta airlines
this to me is the height of scientism
jargon political correctness we've just
got to refer to everything in the most
clinical way possible b
1.617.2 so i'll just jar it's just
jargon that does not actually convey any
information anything that we're actually
talking about but even if by the way
even if these these
employees get the the vaccine it turns
out that the vaccines
just aren't that good so you actually
are going to need a booster shot from
the vaccine even if you just got the
vaccine a couple of months ago this
being pushed
by pfizer by johnson johnson by the
whole blob just one more just 15 more
days just 15 more jabs
just 27 more boosters
johnson johnson
is the latest vaccine company to come
out and say that people who took it are
going to need a booster
joining pfizer pfizer was the two-shot
vaccine you remember you got the first
one you wait a few weeks you get the
second one then you're good
99.99 127
protection from the vice it's the
greatest vaccine ever made
it wasn't rushed i mean i know they made
it in like five minutes but it's not
hasty it's not rushed it's totally
there's no side effects well okay maybe
there's myocarditis and periocarditis
and it's happening in young healthy
people but
there's no johnson johnson one one and
done was johnson and johnson you don't
even need two shots and there's zero
side effects except for the blood clots
that killed some of those women but
there's otherwise there's no well they
did actually have to pause it because it
was that scary but it's fine
now get your booster it's so effective
that you need a booster within a few
months
what
a joke
what
what vaccine have you ever taken
where you need
a booster shot not just it's part of the
series of vaccines but you need an
unaccounted for unexpected booster shot
a few months later
i've never heard of that
you've never heard of that because
the public health bureaucracy
is just making this up as they go along
caught with their pants down making it
up as they go do you know what i think
this is about
i think i think there are broader
economic and political implications here
i think just everything's moving toward
a subscription model you know i think
your your tv obviously is a subscription
model now
uh movies books or unsubscribe your your
software you know microsoft word that's
a subscription model now everything your
your razors are
everything including now
your vaccines are it's okay it's cool
you sign up
for dollar dollar vacs club you know and
every month you get another booster that
you can shoot up to protect you from the
wuhan cough
that poses a grave risk to very
very few people
strange stuff strange how that would
happen i wonder how many we're you know
what we're gonna hear by the way we're
gonna in in six months a year we're
gonna say look it's just just take your
fourth booster it's just the fourth
booster and we can get back to normal
life
and then you know what the conservatives
are gonna say they're gonna say hey guys
you shouldn't take your fourth booster
look
maybe your third booster is fine but you
shouldn't take your fourth one hey
they're gonna say you know you need to
wear
15 masks whenever you go outside and
your kids need to wear 20 masks and you
know what the conservatives are going to
say they're gonna say hey hey that's
crazy
19 at most
that's what they're going to do that's
that's been the effectiveness of of the
conservative movement for many years now
there is there are inducements to get
you to take the shots and the boosters
and everything
you remember bill de blasio that slob
that disgusting man the mayor of new
york would go out and he had he had
seriously in public he had a
cheeseburger and french fries
and he like an animal and to us who he
certainly considers to be animals he
starts chewing in the burgers oh good
burger
take the experimental drug let me shoot
you up then you get free burger
yes hogs will give you extra slop if you
let us inject you with these chemicals
and french fries you know so
de blasio
pioneered this this method
but but different companies have been
following suit including krispy kreme
and i love look i love krispy kreme i
love the burgers that de blasio was
talking about krispy kreme
has been offering people a free donut
if they show their vaccine card
anytime any krispy kreme you show your
vaccine care you get a free donut
pretty good
that's that's right i i would love a
free donut
that's not attracting enough people to
get the vaccine
so now
krispy kreme is offering
two free donuts
so you know our society's become
extraordinarily decadent
one free krispy kreme is not enough to
bribe us into taking the chemicals you
need two you need two crispy who eats
two krispy kremes at a time that's too
much
now the daily caller pointed this out
there is an irony to krispy kremes
campaign
namely
78
of kovid hospitalizations
have been of obese people
one of the you'll hear very often
that there are disparities in the people
who are going to the hospitals one was
that black people are being affected
people of communities of color are being
affected
much much more than white community is
it because the virus is racist the virus
is it's a white supremacist virus from
giants a chinese white supremacist virus
no
it's
because the
actual criterion that will determine
what
how severe the infection will be
one of the most severe ones is obesity
and black people are much more likely to
be obese especially black women
so in order to solve this problem of
public health
krispy kreme giving out some of the
fattiest sugariest donuts on earth
people stuffing their faces i'm sure
that'll fix it right
right
the cdc is pushing it too carrot and
stick you know there's the carrot of the
krispy kreme and then there's the stick
of the government and the government is
coming out and demanding
that people take their vax boosters
we are told by the cdc quote the
vaccines remain highly effective against
hospitalizations the bulwark they
provide against infection with the virus
is weakened
so
the vaccine they're trying to have their
cake and eat it too the vaccine is very
very effective very effective um they're
really good they they're they stop you
know
the
hospital but the but the infection is
bad okay well if
if it does not prevent infection but it
does prevent any severe complications
from infection
then you're good right why do i need
why do i need the booster well no it's
really it's a great vaccine but you need
you need to shoot it up again because
it's not working okay if you want more
information on the vaccines
i've got even worse news for you
the federal government does not have its
act together there either joe biden
president biden trying to avoid talking
about afghanistan trying to exclusively
talk about kovid because according to a
daily wire poll we just put out
people are blaming him for afghanistan
it's really hurting his poll numbers but
the only positive he's got going is his
handling of covid
so he says if you want information
go to vaccines.com
if you go to vaccines.com
vaccines.com
or
text your zip code to 438829
now for those of you who are listening
to that rather than watching it
you will have missed that joe biden is
standing in front of a giant backdrop
on which is written at least five times
vaccines.gov
not vaccines.com
go to joe 303303030
not not totally with it maybe he should
not be
the main spokesman here meanwhile
we sort of alluded to this with the
krispy kreme mention
there are
negative
side effects unintended consequences of
the covid lockdowns and all the covid
measures
so you see it very clearly krispy kreme
here show your vax card oh you're
healthy good we're going to stuff you
full of donuts and put you at a far
greater risk of
of severe complications of coronavirus
in australia it's it's much worse than
that it's much sadder than that
four newborn babies just died in
australia
because of the covid restrictions so
four newborn babies in adelaide
needed heart surgery when they were born
a great number of newborns who need
heart surgery
and
thanks to modern medicine they can get
it taken care of
but
they were not able to get it taken care
of because in adelaide they did not have
the resources to perform the heart
surgery and they could not be
transferred interstate because of travel
restrictions that are keeping people
locked in their homes
so in order
to prevent
people from getting the cough
in order to prove it because there were
one or two cases in australia and
because of that they locked down
everything
we're not even talking about
lots of deaths or even lots of
hospitalizations just you know some
cases
of the virus that doesn't pose a grave
threat to most people
four newborn cute little babies
died
and their parents are going to have to
deal with that for the rest of their
lives
and a cute little baby whom they carried
for nine months cute little helpless
vulnerable baby was sacrificed
on the altar of neurotic
public health fears over a cough over
over something that for most people
feels like a bad flu actually for a lot
of people it doesn't even feel as bad as
the flu
that's that's bad stuff
that's
that's not not a good situation
for anybody
if it only saves one life it's worth it
that's what andrew cuomo told us during
the covet locked if it only saves one
life and this is this is the fear forget
even a second about the virus itself
forget even just dunking on democrats or
republicans or left or right
this is what happens when society
loses its sense of balance its sense of
of the broader picture when it misses
the forest for the trees during even the
trump coronavirus briefings the only
people who would speak were fauchy and
dr scarf
what about the military we didn't hear
what about the economics advisors we
didn't hear what about it was it was
almost exclusively fouchy and dr scarf
they focused only on public health and
the rest of the country went to pot
that's going on around the world as well
and we still haven't learned our lesson
you know speaking of economics
the daily wire is currently looking for
a podcast marketing manager to join our
marketing team we're also hiring a web
marketing specialist to do
i don't know what i don't know what they
do that'd do a lot of technical stuff on
dailywire.com apply right now go to
dailywire.com careers our team is
constantly growing i think we now have
seven million employees every time i go
in there's like 15 new people that i've
never seen before so keep checking that
careers page for new opportunities also
tonight we've got a backstage 7 p.m
eastern 6 p.m central dailywire.com also
on our daily wire youtube channel do not
miss it also our newest podcast morning
wire has been topping the apple and
spotify charts since its recent release
it's the only daily news podcast that
values your time and the truth so
subscribe start listening now to morning
wire and apple spotify wherever you
listen to your podcasts and leave a five
star review if you like what you hear
we'll be right back with a lot more
a lot of death on the mind these days so
kind of a morbid
thing when we've got hearing about
afghanistan we're hearing about the
coronavirus we're hearing about the
victims of the covet lockdowns
but sometimes when you find out people
are going to die it's not the worst
thing in the world like for instance
dylann roof dylan roof is the guy who
murdered a bunch of black people in a
church
in in cold blood he knew some of these
people but he had these sort of racial
theories that he was he's a white
supremacist type guy and so he just goes
in in cold blood
murders them all and he is convicted of
this and then he's sentenced to death
then he appealed his death sentence and
then it was affirmed yesterday he will
be
placed on death row and ultimately
executed by the state
now i noticed something there were there
were some people
who said i opposed the death penalty and
i opposed the death penalty even for
dylan roof but for most people when i
was seeing most of the commentary on
this popular and otherwise it was people
saying something to the effect of look i
oppose the death penalty
but there are exceptions
yeah we're getting yeah i oppose the
death penalty except for this guy yeah
i'm not going to miss this guy and i i
just think they're missing the point
entirely that's actually the worst take
you can possibly have on the death
penalty in my view
because
i'm very pro-death penalty i'm pro-death
penalty for the people who are convicted
of their capital offenses and sentenced
to it including dylann roof
i'm pro-death penalty because i think
that it's good for
the question of justice i think it helps
society to understand justice i think it
meets out the just retribution for the
people who have committed the offenses i
think it it offers a deterrent effect
especially when it is carried through
and i think by the way it's
rehabilitative because hanging
concentrates the mind i think that the
death penalty when it is just in a just
system is
totally right i am in agreement here
with
the bible i am in agreement here with
saint paul with the great doctors of the
church saint thomas aquinas among many
others and i am in agreement with many
many many popes throughout history if
that sort of thing is persuasive to you
including the popes saints and including
a
beatified pope who carried out the death
penalty ordered the death penalty
himself in the papal states i think it
is totally a hard-locked case for the
death penalty
and yet
the argument against the death penalty
is just revenge it's i don't think it's
revenge i don't think it's vengeance i
think it's just punishment i think the
state does not carry the sword in vain
but the people who say i oppose the
death penalty except for
this guy
they are engaging in revenge right i
mean they are they are actually
proving their own point on the death
penalty at least as as regards their
view of it the the reason that they
are especially upset with dylann roof is
because he's committed this special
crime of white supremacy but if the
situation were reversed if it were a
black supremacist or something killed a
bunch of white people i strongly suspect
they wouldn't they wouldn't make a big
deal and actually i know that because in
the capital offenses that
do fall closer to those lines they
usually stay mum
this is very bad we either need to have
a standard of justice or we're just
going to descend into various interest
groups clamoring for revenge not not a
very good situation for society which
unfortunately is the way that we're
going which brings me to
brings me to
the news
the news what you are getting on the
news there is a new study out allegedly
a damning study that shows that 22 of
cable news is news
the study finds that hard news in terms
of the statement of facts and on-spot
reporting amounts to just 22.3 percent
of what goes on in cable news that's 9
minutes and 15 seconds of hard news for
every single hour of broadcasting
there is nearly twice as much commercial
time
time for advertisements as there is for
hard news then interviews with
newsmakers account for another 16 of
broadcast time and then the rest
the vast majority of cable news time 60
is commentary from a host or panel
discussions or analysis from a panel of
talking heads
everyone is on the left and the right
they're reacting to this as though this
is an indictment of cable news it's only
22 percent news
60 is just opinion
that sounds about right actually i think
that's probably about right norm
mcdonald's the great the great political
philosopher mcdonald did this bit where
he said that back in the day you only
had half an hour of news per day
you know you just turn on the nightly
news half an hour of news and even then
they'd have some fluff story and now
it's 24 hours of news but actually half
an hour is about right so they just fill
it up with a bunch of other nonsense
there's only so much news
and there are only so many facts
but
even though i know i know around here we
like to say facts don't care about your
feelings and facts are really important
and i'm not i'm not in any way casting
aspersions on facts
but there is more to life than just
plain
shallow narrow facts we also need to
know what those facts
mean
which is where that other 60 percent
comes in and actually the 16 of the
interviews too
it's not enough
to know
that i am
you know i'm a
i'm i'm two hands i'm two feet on my
head shoulders
i'm blood and lungs and kidneys and
organs and guts and gore it's not enough
to know just the kind of plain physical
facts
if i don't know that i'm also a person
and if i don't know that i also have
some meaning and a place in the world
and what that and and some purpose
and context
all right it's not enough to know
that there was an explosion
in kabul
or even that the explosion was
perpetrated by the new isis group
it's also helpful to know
the context of that what that means i
actually think the right is pretty bad
about this
because the left has gone totally into
the realm of feelings the left has gone
into this crazy realm of just everything
subjective and if i say that i'm a
purple spotted elephant then i really am
even if i'm just a dude and so i get
that the right has reacted to that by
focusing in on facts you know we're just
going to talk about the physical plane
incontrovertible facts of the world but
that's not politics
that's not philosophy that's not human
life that's not actually how we
experience the world there's the
physical stuff but then we need to know
what it means
and i think if the right would would
sure keep your focus on facts enjoy your
facts but then go a little further than
that
and if we would recognize that it's
actually it is important to know
how these things make us feel one but
also what they mean in the broader
philosophical theological context i
think that would serve us a lot better
i'm glad good job cable news for not
having so much news speaking of cable
news
shocking story greg gutfeld
is the king of late night comedy
greg gutfeld a fox news host of many
years at this point
now has a late night comedy show
he has a larger audience than jimmy
fallon jimmy kimmel and stephen colbert
which
is even more shocking because he's on
cable and they're on network and many
many many many more people have network
tv than have
cable tv
it's also shocking because they're
hosting traditional comedy shows he's on
the conservative news channel
but he's crushing them he's crushing
them because
people
i think are beginning
to tune out i think the gatekeepers
lost their stranglehold especially with
the advent of the internet they tried to
grab it again with big tech
even that it's not totally working out
for them
and so they're nervous gavin newsom
right now in california new cellini
he's very nervous
he faces a recall election
now it's going on right now it's a yes
or no vote and then if they vote yes to
recall him
then the top vote getter on on the list
of candidates is going to become the new
governor of california
gavin newsom was playing it cool for a
number of weeks
now he's losing it he just had an
interview with my friend alex michelson
and he's turning the fear-mongering up
to 11.
we're going to win uh overwhelmingly we
just have to remind people the
imperative the vote no
on the question that is in front of them
and you say that larry elder is the
clear favorite on the other side
uh so i think there are a lot of people
that have asked me
how much can a governor really do in a
year with a democratic super majority uh
what's the answer to that i mean you can
lie down and veto everything coming out
of the legislature you can veto
everything that comes from the
legislature but there's a veto proof
majority right there is and there isn't
a lot of things are stubborn there's a
lot of diversity even within the
democratic caucus the end of the day you
could start to vandalize all the
executive orders you can eliminate the
masking requirement for public schools
you can eliminate the vaccine
requirements for public health care
workers so many of the things that i
signed through executive order can be
done overnight you can appoint judges
without any oversight and consideration
that's that's going to have an impact
for years and years and years so it is a
profound consequence and also you have
the bully pulpit of the fifth largest
economy in the world
and you have a midterm election coming
up with another california uh who wants
to take out nancy pelosi consequences
are pretty extraordinary pretty pretty
extraordinary man good on alex michelson
ellie i don't think alex is particularly
conservative in fact i think he's a
liberal sort of like a more sane
moderate liberal
but he's pretty fair
he he pushes pretty hard did you see
that he said hey so
the guy who wins the recall is just
going to serve out the remainder of your
term that's not a lot of time and you've
got a ton of democrats in the
legislature so what's the big deal
well there's a well you know it's a
really big deal because he could veto
stuff uh yeah but you've got a
veto-proof majority the democrats do in
the legislature yeah well
but he's got the bully pulpit okay this
is
this is really weak stuff from from
newsome and news is a slick politician
but
what this is about is gavin newsom
trying to hold on to his political
career there won't be a ton of
consequences for democrats there will be
some but there won't be a ton of
consequences for democrats
if larry elder or whoever wins
the election but newsome's political
career almost certainly will be over and
that's what they're really worried about
which is why they're going hard at larry
larry's the front runner if not for
larry elder in this race probably the
recall would not be going as well for
republicans as it is right now
and so here it is
here's the sex scandal here we go
la times larry elder's ex-fiance reports
an alleged 2015
gun incident to the lapd
so we found out too larry elder's
ex-girlfriend is supporting one of larry
elder's rivals in the contest kevin
faulconer down
in san diego i believe it was reported
so
this is the same paper that called larry
elder the black face of white supremacy
just for starters
uh this is not real this is fake i'm
willing to say with almost 100 certainty
this is fake
i'm not saying larry the accusation is
that they were having an argument and
larry elder was cleaning his gun and
this was threatening and this was
abusive so i don't know maybe larry
elder was cleaning his gun or something
i don't think larry elder has ever
threatened his girlfriend or anyone
really with a gun
in any kind of altercation
if this were real
she would have done this sooner this was
six years ago
if this were a real thing she would have
done this six years ago five years ago
four years ago three two or even one
year ago
if this were real
and she said well look i didn't want to
do it at the time he was just a private
citizen then which is bs by the way he
was an extremely influential national
radio host but that's beside the point
huge name recognition go on tv a lot
he she certainly would have done this
when he got into the race right
shouldn't this have come out at least
when he got into the race no it's just
coming out now
because it's getting close
this is bs this happens in so many races
especially when it doesn't happen to
democrats a whole lot but it happens to
republicans when they're threatening the
status quo
well you know i actually i have a
message to all of my ex-girlfriends
every ex-girlfriend out there i'm not
intending to run for you know governor
of california or anything like that but
if i do
right now here's your chance get all
your grievances out whatever i didn't
pick up the tab for dinner one night
whatever you're upset now is the time
because i don't want to hear it
when we're a few weeks from an election
okay
such
such bs i don't think it's going to work
on larry elder
i think that uh look who the larry elder
campaign of it all it's getting some
enthusiasm up there but this is all
going to come down to one question it's
not any republicans gavin newsom should
we kick out gavin newsom or should we
not and the fact that it's this close
tells you california does not like their
democrat governor
speaking of bias against conservatives
the federal communications commission
is now threatening a 5.1 million dollar
fine against two conservative dirty
trickster types
their names are jacob wohl
and john berkman
and their kind of company john j m
burkman and associates
over a 5 million fine from the fcc why
because
wahl and berkman
pulled a political dirty trick
they made
1141
unlawful robocalls
that made
false claims about mail-in voting
this was what their robocall said
quote did you know that if you vote by
mail your personal information will be
part of a public database that will be
used by police departments to track down
old warrants and be used by credit card
companies to collect outstanding debts
they also claimed that the cdc
might might use these data to enforce
vaccinations
so first of all
i don't put anything past the federal
government at this point because they do
a lot of things that they tell us that
they will not do and cannot do for
instance spying on tucker carlson but
even let's say that it's all bogus and
this was this is a dirty trick it was
supposed to suppress some votes
sure
people are saying was intended to
suppress the black vote okay maybe i
don't know i don't know the details of
this
regardless
five million bucks
for for some dirty tricks on robocalls
democrats do this stuff too
democrats go further actually and they
just upend our election process and they
actually violate the state constitution
in the state of pennsylvania for
instance when they're conducting that
election process
but in terms of these calls or the motor
voter the mailing or the ballot
harvesting or whatever they do a lot of
this stuff too
and they don't
get very public five million dollar
fines
i'm not
defending
the dirty tricks of the republicans
i'm criticizing
the double standard
and that it's a distinction that you're
not you're not really allowed to make it
anymore because now if you defend these
guys or if you in any way think this is
wrong you're going to say well what you
want to suppress the black vote you're a
racist you support illegal activities no
i support
selective prosecutions you remember some
years back dinesh d'souza was thrown in
the clink he dinesh d'souza the
perfectly calm nice
scholarly
commentator and
author and filmmaker he was thrown into
a halfway house because he gave a little
extra money to a friend of his from
college who was running in a doomed
senate race in new york and he gave her
a little extra money beyond the limits
of the federal government
and he had to go to the clink and at the
time he said no no i don't i'm not
saying what i did was right
i'm saying that i was selectively
prosecuted
because democrats do this stuff all
all the time
and they get away with it
it's i don't even want to call it
hypocrisy it's just a hierarchy it's
just that the democrats have
one set of permissions and the
republicans have another
and speaking of these kinds of
comparisons
it's a little bit of a vague transition
but speaking of these kinds of
comparisons i've got to get to
tony hawk
tony hawk
a figure from the childhood of many
millennials tony hawk
skateboarding
star video game skateboarding
tony hawk's releasing a skateboard that
includes some of his own blood in it
it's weird and a little bit creepy
i guess the idea is you know i put my
blood sweat and tears into skateboarding
and now you can have some of that too
okay whatever i think it's kind of weird
and creepy but lil nas x who is that
satanist
rapper
he came out
and he said quote now that tony hawk has
released skateboards with his blood
painted on them and there was no public
outrage are you all ready to admit y'all
were never actually upset over the blood
in the shoes and maybe you were mad for
some other reason
little assets you'll recall when he
released his satanist music video where
he's literally twerking on satan and
saying like hell's maybe not the worst
place in the world and we can make
ourselves into the king of hell
i did a did a long exegesis
a long
reading and analysis of that music video
which you can check out elsewhere
little massax released these nike
sneakers that included
pentagrams and scriptural references to
lucifer to satan
and
allegedly a drop of human blood
and people were up in arms over this
it says well tony hawk used blood too
so this is it's you you're just coming
after me because i'm gay you're just
coming after me because i'm black i
don't know you're just because i'm
oppressed
it wasn't the blood per se that people
were upset about
necessarily or well that wasn't a big
part of it
it was what the blood represented
for tony hawk he doesn't have pentagrams
he doesn't have
numerical and scriptural references to
satan
it's just like a weird marketing ploy
you did
it was about
i think at least for me the outrage was
about the overt satanism
but you hear this all the time and this
is a broader problem that you hear in
politics
they'll say michael if you
think that we should regulate
pornography then you're no better than
the left which says that we should
censor conservatives on the internet
you're no different michael no i think
i'm very different because pornography
and first amendment protected political
speech are different
yes the form censorship is the same
but the substance of what you're
censoring
is different
yes the
the symbol here the blood is the same
but the significance of that
is different
and i think we just need to be able to
talk more about
substantive matters this is this was the
david french's big problem when he said
if we ban drag queen story hour then
they're going to ban us from going to
church that was the implication at least
of what he was saying
we can know the difference we can i
promise you
we possess the faculties of reason in
the moral conscience sufficient to tell
the difference between drag queen story
hour and going to church on sunday
sufficient to tell the difference
between
a skateboard marketing gimmick and
an overt satanic liturgy we can do that
we actually
we actually possess those faculty for
now we do for now i actually don't maybe
not for much longer
what
what are we doing who are this it all
comes back to afghanistan this is why
afghanistan is such a lightning rod
you can't build up another country
another civilization another set of
principles and practices and another way
of life
if you do not possess one yourself or if
the one that you once did possess is
disintegrating all around you i'm
michael nolis the michael knowles shall
see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
today on the ben shapiro show secretary
of state anthony blinken admits
americans will be stuck in afghanistan
past the august 31st deadline and you
know what it's their fault that's today
on the bench bureau show give it a
listen